[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre invité est une sorte d'ovni objet
volant on peut dire qu'il l'est d'une
certaine manière non identifiée parce
que son parcours son expertise et sa
capacité à donner de sa personne sont
franchement franchement extraordinaire
un peu extraterrestre même et les
spationautes mais pas n'importe quel
spationautes le plus expérimenté parmi
tous les européens presque 400 jours
dans l'espace en tout la station
spatiale internationale il la connaît
comme sa poche et tout cela et il aurait
pu vivre dans son coin rien que pour lui
mais non il n'a cessé de partager ses
aventures avec le public il a été avec
nous et nous avons été avec lui durant
toutes ces expéditions il a essayé de
tout dire de tout montrer d'ailleurs je
ne suis même pas sur moi aujourd'hui
pouvoir vous apprendre encore des choses
sur lui mais je vais quand même essayer
c'est mon défi du jour bienvenue dans un
monde un regard bienvenue thomas pesquet
merci infiniment d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ici au dôme tournon au sénat
c'est un peu notre capsule à nous merci
d'accepter encore de partager des choses
avec nous qu'est-ce que vous n'avez
d'ailleurs jamais encore partager avec
le public et que vous accepteriez de
nous dire ici aujourd'hui je ne sais pas
un petit secret une dispute dans les ssd
choses qui pour ne pas avoir encore été
dit sur vous non il ya plein de choses
qu'on peut être s'est dit c'est vrai
qu'on a on j'ai partagé beaucoup de
choses mais évidemment on construit
toujours un peu la communication c'est
un peu le le miroir aux alouettes des
réseaux sociaux on montre les choses qui
vont bien les choses qui sont jolies
parfois ça va j'essaie aussi d'insister
sur les choses comme l'envié à la
protection de l'environnement et non pas
sur la planète mais quand on a un petit
coup de blues quand la famille nous
manque quand ça fait un moment que quand
il n'a pas vu quand il ya une expérience
qui marchent pas ou quand on va casser
un truc ben c'est pas évidemment ce
qu'on va partager dans quoi il ya déjà
des petits moments comme ça ex passe de
temps en temps et pourquoi cette
générosité ce que vous diriez que c'est
l'époque qui veut ça vous vous êtes
laissé prendre au jeu des réseaux
sociaux ouais je pense il ya bien
vraiment plusieurs choses en fait je les
fais un peu sans réfléchir je suis pas
le premier déjà l'avoir fait il ya des
gens qui l'ont fait avant moi peut-être
pas la même échelle ou pas en français
en tout cas
mais
mais ouais je me suis pris au jeu je
pense qu'il ya un côté pédagogique en
fait je suis un peu vient d'une famille
de profs mes parents sont profs mon
frère aussi donc il ya peut-être cette
fibre d'expliquer je pense qu'on est
aussi un peu un service public dans le
spatial donc on a un peu une
responsabilité de dire aux gens ce qu'on
fait avec leur argent pourquoi on le
fait est qu'on le fait pour eux en fait
on n'est pas dans notre tour d'ivoire et
puis je pense que finalement ça me
permettait peut-être aussi un petit peu
de briser cet isolement ce huis clos de
la station spatiale pendant 200 jours à
chaque fois deux fois là au moins ça ça
a amené un peu de un peu de fraîcheur un
peu de communication même si elle était
que virtuelle et puis des changes avec
les gens c'est ce que j'allais vous dire
alors on peut me reprocher de faire un
peu de psychologie me c'est aussi une
manière de vous sentir moins seul de
vous êtes un peu aussi addict aux shoots
de like comme ça vous fait du bien ça
vous remonte le moral quand vous avez
ces petits moments de blues paris mouche
moi je pense je suis pas meilleur que
tout le monde c'est vrai que le sentir
qu'il n'y a que ça intéresse les gens
qui l enthousiasme qu'il ya plein de
plein de sentiments positifs en fait
offert autour de ça donc c'est sûr que
c'est sympa pour moi je ne vais pas le
cacher après ça des conséquences
différentes sur ma vie maintenant c'est
certain mais mais non moi j'ai la chance
par rapport à d'autres carrières ou
d'autres domaines que l'essentiel des
gens qui me qui me parle que ce soit sur
les réseaux sociaux dans la rue ils me
disent des trucs super sympa super
positif donc donc non non c c'est
incroyable ce que vous suscitez
effectivement vous suscitez ce que vous
dites c'est sentiment très positif
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce que vous
direz que vous avez rencontré le public
vous avez été en osmose avec le public
vous êtes en phase avec les français
comment expliquer cela c'est une
renommée incroyable on avait conscience
vous le voyez en sortant de chez vous en
france
bah je sais pas en fait je pense qu'il
ya bien alors déjà il ya le potentiel de
rêve de l'espace de l'exploration en
général de l' aventure ces choses là qui
sont non on n'en a pas vu le bout on
verra jamais le bout je pense l'espace
la dernière frontière les gens savaient
fait quand même rêver l'infiniment en
grand des choses qui sont difficiles à
comprendre qui nous intrigue qui nous
font réagir donc il ya ça et ça c'est
vraiment indépendamment de moi je pense
et puis après
je sais pas la différence est peut-être
j'ai essayé de le faire un peu sans
langue de bois c'est vrai que
traditionnellement dans le milieu des
astronautes on dit toujours non on n'a
pas peur on a pas mal on les super héros
font est un peu cette espèce de
d'attitude sur armouet excuse moi je
trouvais un peu au final contre
productive au contraire dans moi je dis
aux gens bah ouais ça fait super peur de
se mettre sur une fusée ça fait super
mal quand on est en scaphandre pendant
sept heures et en métal sur les
articulations donc je sais pas peut-être
c'est ça aussi il me trouve ça peut-être
plus proche d'eux que ce espèce d'image
un peu trop lisse ou un peu trop c'est
pas virtuel vous savez si vous avez créé
des vocations à j'espère alors oui non
seulement j'espère parce que c'est aussi
pour ça que je les fais quand même moi
je me revoyais temps petit ça
m'intéressait et puis on est un peu
sevré de l'information là je me dis au
moins mais voilà les gens que ça
intéresse qui n'ont pas d'excusé vous
avez tout à portée de main et puis alors
j'espère non seulement et puis où il n'y
a rien qui fait plus plaisir que quand
les gens me disent voilà ma petite fille
maintenant veut être payé wilson qui
était moi ma collègue commandant de la
station quand moi je c'était ma première
mission que tu es ma chef des choses
comme ça et à la sélection d'astronautes
qu'on est en train de faire en ce moment
pour l'agencé spatiale européenne sur
vingt mille candidats pour toute
l'europe il y en a sept mille qui sont
françaises et français donc plus d'un
tiers ses énormes en proportion c'est
beaucoup plus que les autres pays si
vous allez rien le rêve spatial tant
mieux way tant mieux parce que parce que
je pense que les défis techniques
technologiques on en a besoin dans le
futur ya pas que ça évidemment il ya
plein de choses à faire mais quand même
c'est une grosse partie des problèmes
qu'on va devoir résoudre sur la planète
on essaie de leur trouver une solution
technique technologique encore une fois
il n'ya pas que ça mais ça passe par là
voilà si on peut amener les gens avec
enthousiasme dansez dansez carrière là
bas tant mieux est ce que quand on prend
de la hauteur physiquement comme vous le
faites hauteur maximum on en prend aussi
intellectuellement philosophiquement
spirituellement je joue et j'ai envie de
dire mais à son petit niveau parce
qu'encore une fois on est on est pas des
on n'est pas des philosophes on n'est
pas les intellectuels
[Musique]
on
on est vraiment on est vraiment un job à
faire à bord de la station c'est vrai
que la plupart du temps on est assez
terre à terre même même toute la
communication qui ont fait ce que les
gens ont vu moi je faisais ça vraiment
le soir donc une journée de 12 heures
qui se passe et ensuite on fait ça quand
on a le temps
mort où tout d'un coup on faisait des
questions sur l'humain que vous voyez
infiniment petit en soute vous ouais
c'est vrai que ça fait réfléchir c'est
ici une mise en perspective je le dis
souvent mais vraiment je pense qu'on est
pas on est très peu équipés ou très mal
équipé pour raisonner avec des choses
qui nous dépassent on est très humain
c'est très animal on arrive en fait à
raisonner avec des choses qui sont à
notre échelle un nombre de personnes
fini des concepts qui sont assez fini on
se donne les moyens de raisonner un peu
plus que ça avec les mathématiques la
philosophie mais quelque part ça nous
échappe un peu intellectuellement on y
arrive mais mais sentimentalement ça
nous ça nous attache pas et là vraiment
de mettre la terre à une échelle où on
peut l'apercevoir on va dire
sentimentalement ou avec ses sens global
dans sa globalité ça fait ça fait
vraiment une différence et on se rend
compte avec les choses bêtes moi
j'essaie de prendre en photo des villes
qui sont à l'intérieur des terres comme
strasbourg ou je sais pas pourquoi je
pense à strasbourg mais c'est impossible
parce que vraiment on a ces cartes avec
les traits rouges qui sont passées mais
c'est complètement impossible dès qu'on
n'est pas sur un trait de cause je
savais pas si j'étais à strasbourg à
stuttgart et à munich à luxembourg ou à
bruxelles donc moi c'est vrai que ça
fait un tout petit peu réfléchir sans se
lancer dans les grandes considérations
philosophiques les gens reviennent quand
même un peu apaisées et puis avec
beaucoup de modestie sur la place de
l'humain dans l'univers parce que c'est
quand même tout petit quand vous voyez
quand même vous vous et quand ils vous
arrivent de philosopher vous vous dites
quand même que l'humain l'être humain
passé un peu à côté de l'essentiel où on
n'est pas danser
je pense qu'un peu comme nous dans la
station spatiale on est ici
on peut pas non plus moi je trouve ça
compliqué de se confronter toujours à
des grands problèmes fondamentaux sans
solution on peut le faire un petit peu
mais si on fait trop on devient fou moi
je pense donc tout le monde se raccroche
à des choses qui sont qui sont à notre
portée qui sont mesurables sur lesquels
on peut avoir un impact mais ça c'est
important je pense pour pour sentir
utile pour se sentir bien et pour pas
devenir fou donc c'est ce qu'on fait
nous dans la station fait notre travail
et puis on regarde par la fenêtre on
prend un peu un shoot d'adrénaline sur
l'immensité du cosmos mais on
deviendrait fou si on regarde à celles
ci ont regardé ça en permanence je pense
que les gens sur terre font un peu la
même chose ils essayent d'avoir leur
leur impact autour d'eux il essaye de
faire le maximum et ça qui est important
au final au final on peut pas faire
grand chose on viendra tout à l'heure
sur l' iss on va d'abord revenir sur
votre parcours aux personnels et sur ce
qui vous a amené à devenir pilote puis
astronautes spationautes dit on d'abord
les origines c'est en normandie que tout
commence pour vous vous y avait passé
toute votre enfance et vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure vous êtes fils de prof de
maths physique et d'une institutrice
vous allez faire votre maternelles
primaires et collèges à auffay c'est
entre rond ne riez pas
il parie que vous vouliez être pilote
dès le plus jeune âge pourquoi pourquoi
alors d'une bonne question je ne sais
pas j'ai jamais il n'y avait rien dans
ma famille qui me prédestinait à ça
vraiment très très loin de
l'aéronautique du spatial encore plus
mes grands parents agriculteurs les
parents profs et voilà dans ce sens mis
du la petite ville de 2000 habitants une
nulle part face il y avait quand même la
ligne de train c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle on habitait là et
je sais par une espèce de fascination et
de petit garçon en fait ça aurait pu
être le football ça aurait pu être autre
chose et moi je sais pas je pense que
c'était d'évoluer dans les trois
dimensions en fait cette espèce de voir
la terre de haut j'aimais bien les
cartes aussi ça me fascinait avec art la
géographie une manière j'ai enfin la
géographie j'ai pas fait d'études vidéo
a filmé les cartes de manière générale
je pense s'être vu de hausse espèce de
vue d'ensemble c'était ça qui
m'intéressait mais je n'y connaissais
rien et puis au final berger fait pas
par pas vers ceux vers ce parcours
normandeau naissance et puis le
toulousain d'adoption toulouse votre
ville de coeur l'asile d'airbus elle a
quelque chose de particulier cette ville
pour vous notre histoire c'est c'est là
que c'est là que j'ai fait mes études
enfin une partie de mes études en école
d'ingénieur et c'est vraiment là que
avant d'aller à toulouse j'avais 20 ans
j'avais jamais pris l'avion de ma vie en
fait j'étais très peu j'avais su j'étais
parti en vacances avec mes parents
voiture on a fait quelques incursions
delà des frontières mais vraiment pas
beaucoup donc très local vraiment des
racines c'est important aussi et ensuite
d'aller à toulouse je me rappelle très
bien la fois que j'ai la peau pris
l'avion pour la première fois avec mon
sac pour aller faire mes études et c'est
là que tout a commencé en fait parce que
j'ai appris des nouvelles langues
étrangères je suis allé faire des années
d'études à l'étranger j'ai passé mon
brevet de pilote c'est quelque chose
serait pas pu me payer moi même je pense
mais grâce à l'école j'ai pu faire ce à
tarif réduit j'ai rencontré des gens je
me suis vraiment ouvert j'ai déployé un
peu mais elle essaie saka saka tous
lancés pour moi dans ma vie est
tellement ouvert qu'aujourd'hui vous
parlez six langues le français l'anglais
le russe l'espagnol le mandarin et
l'allemand vos passions vos hobbies sont
innombrables vous jouer du saxophone
vous êtes ceinture noire de judo vous
faites du basket du jogging de la
natation du squash du rugby du vtt du
kitesurf de la voile du ski de
l'alpinisme fait de la plongée
sous-marine oui vous riez et du
parachutisme il ya une boulimie
d'activité alors il ya beaucoup de
choses que j'ai plus du tout le temps de
faire parce que très honnêtement c'était
il ya eu beaucoup de choses que je
faisais avant de devenir astronaute vous
savez les faire rouler la préservation
version non mais c'est je suis pas hyper
actif mais j'ai vraiment besoin de
m'occuper
pendant toute ma jeunesse et d'ailleurs
je remercie mes parents parce que j'ai
vraiment ils passaient leur temps à me
trimbaler moi et mon frère un à droite à
gauche entre le club de basket le club
de judo le club de musique c'est
important pour eux qu'on vraiment qu'on
est un spectre un peu plus large que
vraiment juste le côté scolaire alors
que venait de vraiment ce milieu là et
du coup ils ont insisté je me rappelle
il y avait des fois où j'avais pas envie
d'aller à l'entraînement ont permis
d'avancer dans l'histoire c'est
entraînement de judo
tout ça c'est quoi c'est l'adrénaline
c'est non c'est vraiment le souhait
d'apprendre moi j'adore apprendre des
choses nouvelles vraiment je ne sais pas
si c'est une qualité parce que parfois
je m'en souviens pas un peu un défaut
mais c'est vrai parce que il faut pas
non plus complètement trop se disperser
en fait il ya aussi des carrières qui
sont les carrières d'experts ont fait
une chose mais on l'a fait à fond et je
pense que c'est nécessaire pour vraiment
bien faire quelque chose profondément il
faut vraiment y passe et 10000 20000
trente mille heures moi j'ai tendance
parfois
peut-être un peu trop me disperser entre
des choses différentes j'essaie quand
même d'avoir un niveau certes un judo
jusqu'à s'asseoir ouais mais mais mais
j'aurais pu ensuite continuer pendant
très longtemps qu est ce que vous ne
tentez jamais quel sport ou quelle
aventure vous ne tentez jamais vous
regrettez davance de ne pas pouvoir le
faire par manque de temps brb manque de
capacités aussi j'imagine pas parfait
vous ne savez pas tout faire maintenant
je deviens toi j'espère que vous
regrettez de ne pas pouvoir faire
jeu mais je viens bien pas grand chose
que jusque qu'on m'interdise que je
m'interdis de le faire est là en
revenant de l'espace en plus j'ai plein
de projets
mais non non je n'ai pas fait beaucoup
de choses en solitaire en fait quand
j'ai fait du bateau des choses comme ça
ou l'alpiniste c'est toujours en groupe
donc je ne sais pas peut-être des choses
peut-être fois je me lance dans les
choses plus en solitaire parce que en
groupe on a tendance à se reposer un peu
sur les autres aussi
et voilà je sais pas les peut-être de la
voile en solitaire ça serait bien mais
je suis très très très loin d'avoir le
niveau de le faire donc le côté
solitaire en tout cas vous recherchez un
peu quand même ce côté je veux juste
montrer un peu de ça être seul aussi
parfois ne sait pas que ça manque mais
jeu mais je vois bien que c'est quelque
chose que j'ai pas en fait que moi je
suis assez grégaire comme personnage
tendance à bram en avant tant de bien
avec les gens et du coup je me dis
peut-être c'est un truc qui manque en
fait peut-être ça m'apporterait quelque
chose peut-être me trouverait quelque
chose et je fonctionne aussi un petit
peu comme ça c'est vrai quand je pense
avec soi même confronté à soi-même oui
mais juste tout simplement parce que
c'est peut-être une faiblesse que j'ai
jamais l'avoir fait peut-être je me
découvrir quelque chose je sais pas d'où
que donc il faut explorer ces choses là
il faut pas non plus rester dans les
choses qu'on sait faire dans sa zone de
confort il faut à l'expérimenter
vous avez donc à votre actif deux
expériences dans l' iss la station
spatiale internationale je rappelle les
dates pour les gens qui nous écoutent de
novembre 2016 à juin 2010 est dans le
cadre de la mission proxima je fais pas
d'erreur puis du 23 avril au 8 novembre
2021 et lors de cette deuxième mission
vous deveniez le vous devenez le premier
français commandant dit ss avec du recul
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous ont
appris ces deux expériences sur vous et
sur les autres peut-être alors ça m'a
appris évidemment énormément de choses
parce que c'est ces deux missions alors
isolément prise comme ça déjà c'est
quand même quelque chose mais il faut
voir quand même tous les années
d'entraînement qui qui nous amène à ça
apprendre le russe apprendre le chinois
laisse confronté à des gens qui sont
différents se mettre dans des situations
compliquées allez un petit peu au bout
de soi même physiquement faire des
stages de survie sans rien manger
pendant trois quatre jours décrit comme
ça vous deviez retenir une chose que
vous ont apporté ces deux expériences je
pense que ce que ça m'a apporté c'est
que c'est que vraiment il ya très peu de
limites à ce que à ce que l'humain peut
faire je parle pas pour moi mais je dis
en général et ça vraiment c'est vrai
quand on voit la station spatiale c'est
un truc incroyable c'est de la science
fiction il ya vraiment il n'ya aucune
j'ai envie aucune raison qu'on est qu'on
soit arrivé à faire ça parce que c'est
tellement complexe c'est l'étoile noire
de star wars qui volent dans le ciel
c'est des dimensions incroyables c'est
d'une complexité infinie
c'est des gens qui sont jamais vu sur
terre qui habitent à des milliers de
kilomètres qu'on arrive qu'ils sont
arrivés à faire ça ensemble donc on
souvent parlant une langue étrangère et
en s'écrivant des emails etc des modules
qui ont été assemblés enfin c'est
vraiment
internationale et puis je me dis on
vraiment on a pas d'émission c'est faire
ce truc là mais on sait tout faire il
n'y a aucun problème et il faut juste
qu'on est les bonnes priorités que tout
le monde tire dans le même sens et
d'agent général ça se passe bien ça m'a
donné une espèce de confiance alors ont
confiance et faire attention maintenant
quand les choses en plus le monde est un
peu difficile donc je veux pas dire que
tout va bien parce que sinon les gens
arrêtent de faire des efforts mais moi
je dis qu'au fond de moi je suis quand
même un petit peu optimiste sur ce qu'on
peut faire quand on s'en donne les
moyens vous y est attaché à cette
station spatiale internationale à ce
lieu qui est parfois l'objet d'
instrumentalisation politique qui
devient même un objet de pression ça
vous fait mal de voir cela ouais c'est
dommage parce que moi je cette station
je la vois vraiment comme comme un
exemple en fait un taux firmament de la
physiquement mais mais aussi quelque
part manière symbolique de la
coopération internationale c'est des
gens cons et malheureusement on le voit
des velléités as à s'opposer fin des
tendances à s'opposer qu'on essayait de
se mettre ensemble au vu et au su de
tout le monde qui se sont liés et pour
le meilleur et pour le pire un petit peu
on n'est ce pas plutôt pour le meilleur
et moi je pense que cette influence là
elle est extrêmement positive que les
gens nous voient travailler tous
ensemble américains russes européens
japonais canadiens dans la station
spatiale cocon puissant plus le
communiqué à la terre mais j'espère que
ça apaise tout le monde j'espère que sa
une une un effet extrêmement positif
c'est symbolique quand tu car symbolisme
il faut absolument essayer de garder ça
pour le pour le futur on a tendance à se
poser très facile en fait d'insister sur
les différences pour faire des
généralités pour s'opposer c'est plus
compliqué trouver les choses qu'on a en
commun quand on les a trouvés ça sent et
sont élus naissance à une belle et bien
il faut essayer ça dure le plus
longtemps possible on peut faire des
choses extraordinaires alors vous disiez
que vous adoriez les cartes gens des
ruines pour vous et vous là je voulais
donner c'est une archive qui nous a été
transmise par les ja les archives
nationales ils sont nos partenaires sur
cette émission c'est un planisphère qui
date de 1950 à une époque où il n'y
avait pas encore de satellites ça change
un peu quand même lui qui avait
l'habitude de voir la terre comme ça
lorsqu'il est temps sombres ce sont les
forêts
c'est peut-être qu'il va nous amener
d'ailleurs à parler un peu d'écologie
parce que je sais que c'est un sujet
aussi important pour vous vous qui
connaissez si bien la planète qui
l'avait vu sous tous les ongles j'ai
envie de dire comment il va cette
planète alors elle va il ya bien il ya
des challenge comme on dit
globalement j'ai envie de dire
heureusement je pense que la planète la
planète nous survivre à la planète elle
même va aller bien va trouver un moyen
d'équilibrer les choses après c'est
plutôt pour nous que ça va mal se passer
c'est plutôt un problème pour la race
humaine que pour la planète en général
on ne pas avoir le même destin que les
dinosaures certains mais non il ya bien
il ya énormément d'endroits qui sont pas
touchés par les humains on le voit dans
le sahara
les chaînes de montagnes qui ont
tendance à être très très beau par
contre les endroits où on a le plus
d'êtres humains malheureusement c'est
moins joli à part la nuit qu'il ya des
lumières mais on peut se poser la
question de la pollution lumineuse et au
jeu mais
non on va dire encore une fois j'essaie
d'être un peu raisonnablement optimiste
il ya plein d'endroits où ça va bien
mais on note quand même assez nettement
le les effets néfastes de l'activité
humaine et ça se voit à l'oeil nu depuis
la station quand vous étiez dans l'île
c'est sûr que vous avez assisté à des
catastrophes naturelles ans durant à vos
missions à des choses très
impressionnant des ouragans des tempêtes
tropicales des feux de forêt qu'est ce
que vous ressentiez en voyant cela
j'imagine une immense impuissance ouais
exactement parce que nous on est quelque
part on est on est bien à l'abri à 400
km d'altitude on est en plus un peu aux
premières loges pour regarder ce
spectacle kaka un côté et c'est tragique
de dire ça mais qui a un côté en plus
absolument magnifique entre guillemets
enfin vraiment voir là la force de la
nature un nouragues en tant qu ils
touchent pas la terre et qui a pas de
victimes c'est assez magique de le voir
par contre ben du coup on est
extrêmement mauvaise conscience d'avoir
cette vision là quand on sait ce qui va
se passer derrière une fois que
l'ouragan va toucher le va toucher la
côte mouais beaucoup d'impuissance et
puis un peu de honte parfois parce que
quand on voit les feux de forêt on a eu
énormément de feux de forêt les ravages
des feux de forêt mais la plupart
malheureusement ils sont souvent
d'origine humaine et en plus attisé
c'est le cas de le dire par le
réchauffement climatique et par les
choses qui sont aussi de notre fait donc
quand on voit ce lit mes mains c'est
nous qui faisons ça et non mais votre
conscience écologique s'est formé forget
pour pendant vos missions pendant ma
première mission cette solution gt gt
sensibles à ça je pense comme les gens
de ma génération et les gens de la rue
les générations suivantes encore plus
évidemment et puis par le jeu de
connaissances personnelles notamment
d'un compagne qui travaille pour les
nations unies cité des sujets qui me
tenait à coeur mais vraiment c'est ce
recul et mais c'est moi c'est comme ça
que l'expliquent entre comprendre
intellectuellement le réchauffement
climatique et puis voir les effets
pouvoir les ressentir et les voir à son
échelle c'est pas du tout la même
expérience et je pense qu'on est
beaucoup plus équipés pour intégrer le
deuxième cas de figure que le premier
j'ai une question quand même un peu
provoc est ce qu on peut être écolo tout
en participant à des opérations qui
brûle autant de kérosène
question est-ce une question non mais
c'est une très bonne question est ce une
question qu'il faut poser une
classification moi je me pose
quotidiennement en fait qu'est ce qu'on
fait je pense que les gens aussi cela
pose tout ce qu'on va faire en tant
qu'être humain quelque part a un impact
sur la planète utiliser son téléphone
regarder la télé de venir en voiture se
chauffer et c est la question c'est wes
kong où est ce qu'on met la limite en
fait qu'est-ce qu'on fait comment se
positionne collectivement et
individuellement et sera de vivre et
nous ce que ce que vraiment ce qu'on se
dit la réflexion qu'on a dans les
agences c'est que le les conséquences
pour la planète de nos activités elles
sont
super positive parce que c'est vraiment
depuis l'espace surtout avec nos flotte
de satellites ce n'est qu'on mesure le
changement climatique on peut mesurer la
fonte des glaces qu'on a des images
qu'on a des données pour les
scientifiques donc dans la même dans la
balance je pense qu'on est très très
très largement positif c'est que c'est
ça qu'on se dit mais effectivement dès
que ça commence à devenir 50 50 voire
négatif voilà à priori vous changer ses
habitudes alors lors de ces deux
missions toujours vous avez aussi
réalisé plusieurs sorties
extravéhiculaires qu'est ce qu'on
ressent quand on fait ce genre de sortie
dans le vide en ses dires dans le vide
mais
on ressent de oui delà de la peur j'ai
envie d'y refaire de l'appréhension
c'est hyper impressionnant c'est hyper
impressionnant parce que c'est comme en
fait c'est comme une escalade avant aux
dunes d'une paroisse immense on a quand
même 400 km2 vite sous les pieds mais il
faut travailler il faut lâcher la
paroisse en fait pour on est juste un
crochet avec une longue on flotte comme
ça on travaille avec les autres avec les
deux mains et cette espèce de flottaison
qu'une chute lente
et c'est pas toujours hyper hyper
confortable donc on fait très très
attention au début moi j'avais beaucoup
de mal à lâcher la station dès demain
même si on est accroché même si on sait
qu'on va pas tomber c'est quand même
hyper désagréable de lâcher de voir la
station se s'éloigner comme ça on sait
qu'on a une longe donc ça va aller mais
mais globalement c'est hyper actif une
confiance aveugle en l'autre ans celui
qui a fabriqué alors on les vérifie nous
mêmes
des procédures pour les filles vraiment
très très bien et puis il faut apprendre
à son cerveau en fait on fait on fait
exprès on s'accroche avec une 11e on se
pousse et puis ça fait super peur mais
au le cerveau va comprendre au bout d'un
moment que qu'on va pas tomber est-ce
qu'on sort marqué physiquement
psychologiquement moralement de ce genre
d' aventure là micropesanteur empêche
vos muscles de travail et je crois que
vous rentrez vous ne pouvez pas marcher
tout de suite puisque vous connaissez
les effets à long terme alors j'espère
que on m'a dit qu'ils étaient là que
vous pouvez récupérer des effets à long
terme j'espère qu'on va durer mais non
je pense que sur une mission une mission
de six mois il faut à peu près six mois
pour s'en remettre complètement on va
dire donc là pour aller physiquement
physiquement d'accord physiquement donc
vraiment le sur la densité osseuse ça
c'est peut-être le pam est donc on
récupère pas à 100% je pense pas qu'on
récupère 100 % de densité osseuse n'est
pas très grave moi je prends j'étais un
peu plus dense avant l'avant le départ
donc je suis encore à peu près dans les
clous musculairement on peut au ca
prends un moment nous on peut récupérer
sur le cardio aussi parfois il ya des
changements de vision qui peuvent se
passer à cause de la pression crânienne
à l'intérêt de la pression des fluides à
l'intérieur de la boîte crânienne moi
j'ai eu de la chance j'ai pas eu de
changement de vision moralement
moralement ce qui est drôle c'est que il
ya beaucoup moins d'études en fait une
fois qu'on revient mais voilà on nous
sert la main tout va bien on finit le
travail et puis après que tout ça
s'arrête donc ce qu'on trouve un peu
livrés à nous mêmes moi je me rappelle
avoir vécu des moments un peu bizarre où
on se retrouve dans un supermarché cinq
jours après le retour sur terre
qu'est-ce que je fais là au milieu des
gens ces cinq jours j'étais dans la
station spatiale donc c'est il faut il
faut je pensais retrouver un peu sa
place dans la classe aussi dans la
société dans la vraie vie sur terre sur
et auprès de ses amis auprès de sa
famille les gens ont continué à
fonctionner pendant qu'on n'était pas là
gens n'ont pas attendu donc il faut se
réinsérer dans tout ça
ça demande un peu de travail il faut
faire attention et je pense que on a une
phase de six mois après la mission à
l'agencé spatiale où finit la mission
faire un petit peu de communication les
choses comme ça mais on ne donne pas un
boulot tout de suite parce qu'on essaie
de laisser les gens s'habituent est une
espèce de sas avant de reprendre une vie
normale mais la ville ne perd pas pour
autant de son intérêt non il ya des
choses quand même c'est difficile de
retrouver
l'excitation la saveur ou le sentiment
d'une mission spatiale quand même pas ce
que c'est c'est c'est en fait la
convergence de force de tellement de
gens
tellement de d'intelligence des gens qui
construisent les fusées les satellites
et extra qui développèrent
l'entraînement les années de boulot tout
le monde qui tire dans le même sens vers
le même but et puis finalement ce jour
arrive enfin c'est quand un peu comme
les sportifs sont les jeux olympiques je
pense et bien ensuite on continue mais
mais
mais voilà il faut se retrouver des
défis ça crée un grand vide là aussi
mais un autre voilà ça crée aussi
vertigineux je pense qu'il faut pas être
ouais il faut savoir se dire ben voila
j'ai fait ça c'est très bien il faut pas
le regretter toute sa vie en fait je
pense que le piège c'est après tout sa
vie se dire ah là là ça c'était vraiment
bien je vais pas le retrouver c'est
vraiment dommage et c'est être fort en
fait solide quand même un psycho
logiquement fait bien construit bien
assis un bien ou alors pour avoir la
maturité pour se dire tout ça parce que
j'imagine que certains flanche vous
aider à ne jamais senti flanché vous non
je pense mais mais on est je pense qu'on
est sélectionné un peu pour ça et puis
et puis parfois enfin comme je disais
tout à l'heure c'est peut-être un peu
une faiblesse moi je dis parfois je me
pose peut-être pas cette question la
note d'intention j'étais en train de
vous imposer 3
je pense on est sélectionné pour ça on
prend des gens très stable quand même
c'est oui c'est le la qualité principale
je pense qu'aujourd'hui pour les six
mois dans des stations spatiales demain
c'est de faire partie des critères de
sélection vous lisez vous aujourd'hui
well et j'ai des photos pour vous
j'espère que je peux vous déprimer les
goûts avec mes photos ça dépend allez la
première emmanuel macron et vous vous
l'avez rencontré à plusieurs reprises un
emmanuel macron le fait que vous soyez
si fédérateur jamais clivant si
populaire est ce que ça vous a fait
craindre parfois d'être instrumentalisés
utilisé par des responsables politiques
qui aurait bien envie d'avoir votre
soutien officiel voyez alors moi ça me
va pas vraiment fait craint ça l'à
beaucoup fait craindre à ma mère et oui
je sais pourquoi est il aussi je pense à
l'agent spatiale les gens s'inquiètent
un peu de tout ça
non je pense pas je pense justement que
moi j'ai pas j'ai pas vocation en fait
dès que dès qu'on met un pied dans
l'arène politique et il faut le faire
c'est important que les gens qui est le
débat etc mais justement devient client
moi c'est peut-être pas mon rôle moi
j'ai des thématiques qui sont plus
scientifique technique et c'est pas du
tout politique il n'y a pas eu vraiment
de deux ans j'ai rencontré des
responsables politiques à droite et à
gauche évidemment les conseillers ont
bien fondées vous approcher certains ont
bien tenté de vous approcher je suis pas
assez subtil pour avoir encore une
approche c'était très possible ou soit
n'y avait jamais vraiment eu peur
personne est vraiment venu me dire
thomas qu'est-ce que tu penserais de ça
c'est vraiment jamais passé du tout
argent j'ai essayé d'être clair il y
avait eu 1 un pseudo débat une époque
j'étais allé un dîner d'état à
washington
et là il y avait je sais pas quelqu'un
avait lancé l'information je me tourner
vers la politique j'avais fait un
démenti absolument honnête est
absolument clair peut-être que ça ça ça
a servi et si on vous proposait le poste
de ministre de la recherche on à claude
ignorer qu'il a été ma raison savuth là
aussi il y aurait de l'adrénaline
nouvelle aventure nouvelle expérience
ouais je suis pas en train d'essayer de
vous faire dorer on en dire quelque
chose mais c'est vrai que ça peut être
un ouais je pense que c'est difficile
enfin je pense que c'est extrêmement
difficile surtout quand on n'est pas du
milieu enfin du milieu sans que ce soit
quelque chose de péjoratif mais mais
c'est tellement il ya tellement de
relationnel de jeu c'est pas de
d'organes d'organismes de choses bien à
ma passion c'est un monde à part sans
appui en arrivant là dedans connaissant
personne en fait à mon avis on est un
petit peu joué aux échecs quand même
c'est pas votre monde non j'ai une autre
photo qui va vous parler c'est en avion
air france vous avez été longtemps
pilote pour air france vous avez volé
sur airbus a320 et même instructeur sur
a320 je crois jamais l'a380 non l'a380
d'ailleurs c'est fini le dernier a été
assemblé à toulouse en mars 2021
j'imagine que vous avez suivi ce dossier
le patron d'airbus a dit qu'il ne
fallait pas avoir de regrets globalement
notre réflexion sur le secteur
aéronautique dont on dit qu'il n'a plus
beaucoup d'avenir ou moins d'avenir
comment voyez cela avec regret ben non
alors en fait j'essaie là encore
j'essaie de me poser des gsm me poser
des questions
je pense qu'il faut alors déjà on
il ya beaucoup de phénomènes de
je suis peut-être bouc émissaire c'est
un peu fort mais je trouve les gens
n'ont pas envie eux mêmes se sentir
coupable du réchauffement climatique
c'est donc c'est quand même assez
pratique souvent de pointé du doigt en
l'air au nautic peut-être ou d'autres je
sais pas le l'alimentation la viande etc
chacun choisit un peu son truc et dis
moi vu que je le fais pas je suis
vertueux moi je trouve que c'est un
petit peu facile et qui évidemment tout
est toujours compliqué ya rien qui n'est
ni blanc ni noir voilà mon une fois
qu'on a dit ça évidemment fier est plein
de progrès à faire dans l'aéronautique
moi j'essaie toujours de me poser la
question comme tout à l'heure en fait
quel est le quel est le positif qu'elle
est le négatif il s'agit pas d'arrêter
de d'êtres humains est d'arrêter tout ce
qu'on fait de plus parlé depuis se
rencontrer et c'est parce que
l'aéronautique ça a quand même permis de
que les gens se parlent en fait surtout
depuis l'après-guerre que les gens se
connaissent que les gens se découvre que
dès qu'on soit un peu plus unie et qu'en
soit quelque part un peu moins
susceptibles de se faire la guerre c'est
des grands mots mais je crois quand même
un petit peu donc il faut pas que ce
truc là disparaissent je pense il ya une
tendance naturelle tout le monde va se
retrouver dans son coin on le voit
aujourd'hui donc l'aéronautique pour moi
il ya un côté un peu fédérateur après
c'est sûr que on peut pas continuer la
manière dont on l'a fait parce que
perso j'ai hébergé des maladies en fait
j'aimerais bien ça c'est des choses qui
me kim
ouais qui me font même un peu plus
longtemps à m'endormir le soir ou le
matin quand je me réveille mais j'y
pense je me dis en fait je me dis qu'est
ce que moi je peux apporter à la société
avec mes compétences en fait et moi mes
compétences de longs parcours très
grande île c'est ça en fait c'est le
côté opérationnel pratique et c'est
parce que il avancé comme ça à l'époque
donc voilà est-ce que ça ça peut servir
est-ce que ça ça peut être une expertise
dont on a besoin voilà peut-être un jour
je sais pas allez une dernière photo
c'est une photo de coluche
puisque vous avez participé au clip des
de la campagne 2022 vous avez
été la nouvelle recrue de cette année la
recrue à part puisque vous l'avez vous
leur avait même inspiré le clip qui
s'est déroulé dans un le décor en tout
cas du clip ce que ça se déroulait dans
un vaisseau spatial tout cela au profit
des restos du coeur une raison
particulière un attachement particulier
à l'association de coluche ou fait
partie de cette génération marquée par
coluche ouais je pense je me suis
demandée c'est pareil on a en fait on se
retrouve dans cette position de en tant
qu astronautes on peut on a les
américains 18ème bien dit on à une
plateforme on a une plateforme pour pour
parler de sujets qui nous tiennent à
coeur alors les gens le font pas
forcément un mal qu'ils font plus que
d'autres stars faut pas non plus trop ce
se disperser mais mais voilà moi je me
suis lancée dans quelques sujets etc
puis on se dit bas est-ce qu'on peut pas
donner un coup de pouce à quelqu'un
normalement on peut si on peut soutenir
qu'une association oui voilà nous on
sait on s'est arrangé pour faire le
maximum possible et puis c'est devenu un
choix un peu logique encore une fois
pour se dire attendez qu'est ce qui se
passe ou les gens ont besoin d'être ce
que je vois des gens autour de moi qu'on
besoin d'être qu'est ce qu'on va faire
les restos du coeur je pense que c'est
hyper vertueux dans le sens où même leur
frais de fonctionnement sont hyper bas
par rapport à d'autres associations je
suis un peu lancé avec un détail c'est
aller chercher non je voulais le faire
pour de vrai je voulais pas juste monter
sur une scène faire une chanson et que
c'est fait c'est pas salé certains le
font certains faut une norme mais c'est
très bien et du coup et du coup voilà
c'était un choix un petit peu logique
c'est vrai que c'est la grosse
association que tout le monde connaît en
france je pense qu'il fait énormément de
bien il y en a plein d'autres qui sont
plus petit qu'on essaie d'aider j'aide
aussi beaucoup aviation sans frontières
encore une fois c'est mon domaine
mais ça me paraissait un choix logique
et puis un endroit où je pouvais avoir
un peu d'impact voilà aller ce sera ma
dernière question j'arrête la séance de
torture question livres etc ce lieu on
est entouré de quatre statues qui
représentent chacune une vertu vous avez
ici la sagesse la prudence la justice
ici est derrière moi l'éloquence autre
question un peu compliqué est ce que
vous vous reconnaissez dans l'une de ses
vertus en particulier sagesse prudence
justice éloquence nous parle oui on abat
alors je suis que je me reconnais ce
mois je sais pas mais en tout cas je
pense que la sagesse pour moi c'est ce
qui me parle de plus la prudence c'est
pas tellement mon domaine on fait tout
très prudemment messager activité assez
risqué éloquence c'est pas mon domaine
non plus je pense mais mais vraiment la
sagesse c'est important la sagesse et
c'est un peu appréhender le monde avec
avec du recul et essayer de trouver des
idées des valeurs qui transcende un peu
ou des choses qui transcende un peu les
gens qui errent approche moi c'est un
petit peu ça qui m'anime maintenant
après après la mission alors je suis
loin d'avoir atteint sa sagesse mais je
me dis si avec quelque chose vers quoi
t'attendre dans mon plus vieil âge ils
sont invités qui nous parle de la
sagesse merci oui merci merci infiniment
thomas pesquet devrait être notre invité
exceptionnel ici dans un monde un regard
sur public soit merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous et d'avoir joué le jeu de
toutes ces questions parfois
personnelles merci on se retrouve très
vite sur public sénat bientôt
[Musique]